hour of news coming your way president
trump will be out soon for a news
conference live from the white house
and while we wait for that to start the
countdown to election day is on and you
know what that means
the media is ramping up their anti-trump
rhetoric well president trump was
delivering historic mid-east peace deals
between israel the uae and bahrain
members of the press were quick to
downplay it at every turn
take a look as andrea mitchell reports a
broader middle east peace
is still an elusive goal but today's
agreements open the doors for trade
travel and tourism but it is not middle
east peace
left out the palestinians but it's more
of a business deal
than a peace accord the three countries
are not engaged in armed conflict
comprehensive peace across the entire
region president trump proclaiming this
a peace agreement but the countries were
not at war
and left out of the deal the
palestinians
who call the agreement a betrayal and of
course cnn didn't care at all about the
deal
and instead focused on this today's
ceremony showcased the president's
continued defiance
of the very coronavirus guidelines his
white house recommends
there were hundreds of people gathered
with little in the way of social
distances hundreds of guests were packed
on the south lawn
with little social distancing an
optional mask
well that is happening the media and the
democrats have also been hyping that
trump
won't leave office if he loses but what
happens if he wins
how could they accept the results with
months of hair on fire reactions like
this
if he loses trump he won't go i've been
saying that since before he
got elected you have so many
rank-and-file military personnel saying
whoa
we're not a military state this is not
who we are i promise you i'm
absolutely convinced they will escort
him from the white house there is a
process
it has nothing to do with it the certain
occupant of the white house doesn't feel
like
moving and has to be fumigated out of
there
all right juan i want to cite a headline
from the babylon b
before you stop me i know it's a
satirical publication but i think it
really nails what's going on here here's
the headline this is kind of making fun
of cnn
media criticizes trump for ignoring
social distancing guidelines
while saving baby from oncoming train
do you see the kind of snark we're
talking about with cnn we're announcing
this big piece deal
and all these heavy hitters that
probably get tested daily or weekly
are gathered around the white house to
make peace don't you see that's really
not the story
well okay but i mean i got to help you
with your reading selections there jesse
i want to do a little show-and-tell okay
because to me
here's here's what my experience was
this morning as i
i woke up and went to the doorstep uh
looking rather shabby here's what i saw
here
here's the wall street journal this
morning and the wall street journal's
top
picture top story about the israeli deal
oh my gosh and then i picked up the
washington post jesse and look it's the
top story it's a big headline jesse
oh my gosh but you know jesse i even
read sang the
guitars and look look jesse oh my god
the new york times their top story i'm
not saying they ignored it i'm just
saying they spun it negative
didn't you hear the montage at the time
i'm saying
yes but i'm telling you jesse they all
paid attention to this and to what it
means to the middle east
it seems to me that the media didn't
downplay this it seems to me that
i forget the name of your source but it
seems to me like the conservative
echo chamber is playing up and
nitpicking you know anything that talked
about
social distance and the need for it and
mass wearing in the age of coronavirus i
think
that's what's going on it's not that
anybody is ignoring the deal that was
made by the president
okay well i didn't say ignoring i said
they were spinning it negatively greg
you've been talking a lot about the left
wing preparing for violence
whatever happens after the election and
you you're actually right
i hate to admit it because i found an
article in the daily beast
that says the left is preparing for
violence they say there's
there's training for civil disobedience
and mass public
unrest training you had to occupy stuff
and shut things down
and it's a conglomeration of a bunch of
left-wing groups so
i think we have to prepare for the worst
i believe me i am preparing for the
worst because i've seen the worst
and it's going to get worse if that's
even possible and the funny thing is
when you think about this peace deal and
the riots
when there were riots they were calling
them mostly peaceful then you see a
breakthrough in peace
and they don't call it peace they don't
even call it mostly peaceful
so the media is gaslighting the united
states
with everything including literal
gaslighting
remember would people if you raise the
question that maybe some of the
wildfires in oregon were started by
people
the media mocked you they said no no no
no no that's just a
far right conspiracy that you know lurks
in the reddit world
you know and then of course there are at
least two arrests now of arsonists who
were setting fires in
oregon but you were told that that you
what you see with your own eyes
doesn't exist but the reason why the the
media is
is denying this as a peace deal it's
cognitive dissonance right
this is observably the factually a great
thing you got to admit
it's a great thing but they can't do it
so they're crumbling into this cognitive
dissonance denial because the orange
godzilla hitler
isn't really orange godzilla hitler
after all
or he's the worst orange godzilla hitler
ever created
they spent four years trying to
brainwash the public into thinking this
man is evil they wanted all of us to set
our hair on fire
so they deserve to feel terrible
they deserve to have their hair on fire
every i mean they have been wrong on
so many things that if i listed them
we'd be here until 2024
when trump begins his third term hey
don't scare the left too much they might
they might go nuts katie
one of the criticisms now is that oh you
know this isn't really a peace deal
because these three countries weren't at
war with each other
that misses the entire point that now
there's a sunni israeli
alliance against the iranians which have
been responsible for causing a lot of
the
violence in the middle east and that's a
good thing
the argument that this is not a peace
deal it's completely detached from
reality of the way that every arab
country
in the middle east maybe minus egypt
because they were early on in the 1980s
with the peace agreement
with normalization would condemn
everything that israel did
the main issue that was portrayed in the
media and in the arab world was the
palestinian-israeli issue
that is no longer the case what this
deal does for america is it allows the
united states to be less involved in the
middle east
it means more intelligence sharing
between those countries on terrorism so
there will be less
radicalization and terrorism and it
brings new allies to the table in the
fight
against iran and when the media refuses
to
just report what happened here and call
what it is which is a peace agreement
they're doing it for a couple of reasons
the first is that they've been wronged
all of the articles at the beginning of
the administration were that jared
kushner could not
broker a deal on middle eastern peace
because he had no diplomatic experience
on the issue
he came in went about it in a different
way through business and intelligence
sharing
and other offers on the table and got it
done
and there are going to be more and what
that does to people who have been
focused on the israeli
israeli-palestinian issues for decades
in d.c
as it embarrasses them and proves that
the issue is no longer about the
palestinian-israeli issue
but bigger issues in the middle east and
by the way when the media focus
focuses on the palestinians not being at
the table do you know what the
palestinian terrorists were doing
yesterday while this was being signed
at the white house they're raunching
lockets rockets from gaza into israel
which is why they weren't at the table
for the steal
yeah dana take a swing at the coverage
of the peace deal or the
conspiracy theory about trump refusing
to leave the white house
i think we've covered the peace deal
pretty well i think what i would say for
the democrats is
i would be looking at all of these
battleground states
and spending a lot more time figuring
out how joe biden
can win in those states rather than
planning
what to do if he loses it seems to me
that would be
better time better spent at this point
as you see these races tightening up
yeah they could probably do better
organizing
voters and organizing protesters